playoff bracket is set in both
conferences in the nfc the top seed by
virtue of their victory last night at
seattle the san francisco 49 is their
next play on january 11 4 35 eastern on
nbc chris we will be there we will santa
clara for that game number two see the
green bay packers they will host someone
on uh the following day and in the afc
the bracket is set top seed baltimore
ravens kansas city chiefs there you see
the bills and the texans they play in
the texans memorial playoff spot at 4 35
eastern on saturday it seems like the
texans are in that spot every year and
then saturday night
titans in the patriots all right that
leads to a question that we have from
orion chuzzlewit i still think that we
should google that i don't think that's
sure i just feel like that's probably
something we shouldn't have orion
orion chuzzlewit of the 12 playoff teams
which one is closest to now or never
territory for a super bowl run for their
current core of players before the
season i would have said new orleans but
sean payton has proven he can win with
almost anyone at quarterbacks so who's
in now or never
mode well i don't know if i've put
anybody twice in now or never mowed and
i mean i understand uh orion's thought
there with the saints but you know as we
saw the saints went 5-0 with teddy
bridgewater and the three losses are
with drew brees at quarterback plus
there's a lot of young talent in the
saints whether it's camara michael
thomas you know they have that of course
uh
taysom hill the defensive side of the
ball with marshawn lattimore in the
secondary they're still very much in
their prime there a lot of those guys so
i don't look at them you know mike
honestly if i had to pick one team i
think i'd probably pick the minnesota
vikings i was just thinking that i think
so yeah i just look at that and which
means it's never what just means it's
probably never right but you know you
got some defensive lineman and kendricks
that are getting up there in here
linville joseph is getting up there in
years you know anthony barr and
kendricks are still awesome don't get me
wrong but you know they're getting
towards that part of their career where
it's going to be yeah they're in their
prime but it'll start the downslope of
their prime xavier roads as we've seen
that's over he's done harrison smith
his prime is coming to an end as well so
i guess if i had to pick one i would
pick the minnesota vikings if the
vikings get blown out sir on sunday in
new orleans the vikings says
blown up sir sir blown up sir sergeant
halka come on stripes it's on netflix go
watch it but uh
if they get blown up sir on sunday in
new orleans they got some questions to
ask
will kirk cousins be back at quarterback
i mean if he has another performance
like the one we saw last monday night i
don't care about all the weeks he had
great performances that didn't matter i
don't know what this guy's gonna do when
it counts it's this i don't know what
he's gonna do in big games the narrative
continues the one time they broke that
narrative this year was when they beat
the cowboys and in hindsight who
freaking cares yeah that they beat the
cowboys at the time it was a big deal
right now it's not all right what are
you gonna do about your coach he's under
contract through 2020. it feels like the
window's closing and you're right and
and i think that's what's significant
about picking the vikings in response to
this question for the 11 other teams
the window's open right the ravens
aren't going anywhere the chiefs aren't
going anywhere the patriots have a lot
of young talent it's just brady that's
old you know the houston texans ain't
going anywhere buffalo ain't going
anywhere and the tennessee titans aren't
going anywhere 49ers are going to be
around right seahawks with as long as
they have russell wilson and pete
carroll there they're going to keep
rolling right i don't think green bay is
out of that window in fact i think green
bay just restarted a new window era here
to where yeah and it has to happen in
the next few years with aaron rodgers
yeah i'm with you i mean you know and
the eagles may be the team that the
future is the brightest because if they
could just get their regular guys on the
field they wouldn't be the 4c they'd be
the ones seen exactly right they could
stay healthy and then you know they're
another team yeah they just reorganized
their team a little bit in free agency
this year they'll be good for a long
time as well so yeah i guess i look at
the vikings as that team more than
anything and uh you had to be it'd be
interesting and i'm with you the kirk
cousins last showdown in seattle there
if you are not not seattle the green bay
game it was hideous it was hideous it
was hideous by all things with the
vikings like it just what what the
vikings is dude i don't know what it is
no personality no fight no leadership
what is it it just seemed like oh hey
they're kind of railroading us and we
should have controlled the game early
and the packers are dominating us now
ho-hum no big deal here's the problem
when dalvin cook's not available yeah
when they don't have the running game
then they don't have the passing game
that comes off of play action and the
bootlegs that make it easier for kirk
cousins to get rid of the ball to an
open receiver so they have to rely on
traditional drop back passing the
offensive line gets beat as soon as and
i've been saying this all year as soon
as the walls start to close in he's done
he's done he doesn't even try to run
away from pressure anymore i know he
just he just just collapses and it
doesn't work um period you need dalvin
cook now dalvin cook may be back for
sunday which could change things and
when they lost to the saints last year
in the regular season they did not have
dalvin cook he was injured uh if they
did he was he was diminished but he
they've the saints have never faced the
vikings with a healthy and effective
dalvin cook even in the minneapolis
miracle game it was latavius murray
who's now on the saints who was carrying
the load so look i don't expect the
vikings to win i don't expect it to be
close because i believe in the
narratives i've seen
and the only good thing the vikings have
going for them is the game starts at one
o'clock eastern not at night yeah right
like it was at night it would be done
there'd be no chance it would be that
place would be that the roof would be
ready not blocked it has nothing to do
with that it's just the vikings can't
play in a big game at night yeah right
well it i mean to your point so i i
totally hear you you know it's just um
you know again this is what i argue this
is a franchise quarterback if you're
gonna be paid 28 30 million dollars a
year
to me what embodies a franchise
quarterback a little what we saw with
carson wentz lately is when things
around you are not good do you have the
talent to go man the team doesn't have
his mojo tonight or we're not protecting
to our best or we're not running the
ball do you have the talent to go okay
i'm gonna make six or seven plays here
in the second half of this game to pull
us out of this slump and we'll be okay
and that's to me where kirk cousins yeah
i'm i'm with you uh i i can't believe
i'm saying it but it's a it's a little
worrisome now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports